in the Conference Finals against
Milwaukee he was 4 for 23 from
three-point range at 17 percent Kawhi
Leonard nails the three Leonard drives
inside layeth Paxson Hall and the foul
let it drive by curry comes over but
they are not a better basketball team
without Kevin Durant what he does is
makes like so much easier for everybody
and a beautiful path pass from curry say
yeah come with the finish down the other
end he's got ten points on the clock
Leonard searching through some room
Looney comes out on him Leonard shoots
over him and knocks down the three
siakam the play tops amount of direct
coke pumps to help Leonard's left open
good look from siakam baseline side
Leonard just sneaks behind curry bumped
some excellent pass by Sayaka and a good
finish
Steve Kerr talked about it this is the
best and fleet gets inside feets took a
soul misses badly Trayvon Green quickly
throws ahead got a bad pass Leonard with
the steal winners back to Gasol lays it
up and in ball deflected and picked up
Danny Green wide open
Logan's just picked up his first foul it
was on him not cooked Gasol gets it
drives down Allen nice bounce pass some
Leonard and Gasol eight points
[Music]
[Applause]
Leonard gets away from Paulo and frozen
tip and Kawhi Leonard just blowing by
them
[Music]
when our turn shoots his score sees a
machine in leather the rebound Leonard
11 points three boards and his team down
by 11 hits again
well let's take turns it over turnovers
11 to 4 only for the Toronto letter
knocks down another three and the first
lead of the night full of raptors are
you kidding me you want though he's
feeling on the offensive end
draymond Green bird with his ninth
rebound Leonard pull-up jumper tucks it
in Kawhi Leonard dominating right now
five of their first six shots from the
field by Leonard gets inside
Danny Green two pointer good physical
defense
nice double team by Gasol and another
turnover Lowery inside Leonard got hit
out of foul fence event forcing the
Warriors into another turnover and then
it's off to the races
multiple guys in position and quality
offense look at the grown man strength
of Kawhi Leonard gets the contact and
the hoop knocked away there he kicks it
out Thompson shot blocked by Leonard
swatted out of bounds
great recovery by Leonard and then talks
trash to klay Thompson old metal in the
under-16 world championship Lehner's
stutter step a soft touch around the rim
again
[Applause]
Leonard throws it inside siakam off the
glass it's down to long dream right up
into curry Bakke there to help up curry
gets past of lamb shot block soon for
three too strong
draymond Green trying to save it and
cousins comes up with a stolen by
Leonard Leonard nearly travels Leonard
for three
[Applause]
Raptors lead in these finals Leonard
drives pulls up banks at home up into
him five to shoot
Leonard's gonna try another one been
getting destroyed with this principle
the switch cousins on the smaller guy
that's been the number one talk in
sports the debate should he have played
in that game the other night well I
don't know any of the medical stuff and
I wasn't obviously that's the often gets
it done in Golden State win another
title without Kevin Durant here in the
finals Leonard gets inside goes reversed
back Murray shot blocked by Kawhi
Leonard
Leonard to the foul line line drive he
drills it for his second field goal
hurry dances inside flips it up fight
for the rebound Lowry siakam to Leonard
Leonard smart play by siakam throwing it
back and then leant it the catch the
ability to finish off of the catch with
the contact
being cousin loonies struggling to
finish around the rim cousin just
finishing well Leonard finishes and gets
hit and a chance for a three-point play
on him to get to that right hand and he
gets side by side with you game is over
Serge Ibaka inside past Leonard Leonard
counted out a game on green three
pointer rebound Leonard Lowry ahead of
the pack goes up and lays it in great
feet ahead from Kawhi Leonard and it's
back to a two-point game